Tim sorry police have just released a
statement and it's saying that
counterterrorism policing can now
confirm that the stabbing incident that
happened in Redding last night has now
been declared a terrorist incident now I
understand that a libyan national has
been arrested he's thought to be an
asylum seeker it's also thought that he
might have some sort of mental health
issues too and so as things stand and
it's important to stress that this is
very much the early stages of the
investigation it doesn't seem that he is
perhaps a I sort of hardened terrorist
mastermind maybe someone who's perhaps
also has a bit of a sort of more
complicated backstory the investigators
are now looking through his electronic
material his mobile phones trying to see
whether he was acting alone or whether
he was part of of a group
it's thought as things stand that he was
acting alone
but again it must be stressed this is
the very early stages of the
investigation also important to note
that as things stand they don't believe
that there is any connection between
this Libyan national and the Libyan
suicide bomber who blew himself up in
Manchester Arena in 2017 a horrific
attack that killed more than 20 people
many of them children
this incident thought to be very
different that the two men Libyan
nationals that's all they share in terms
of similarities as things stand okay and
Deborah thanks so much let's go back to
our home affairs editor mark white he's
in West London mark just a couple of
hours after this happened last night you
were saying that sources told you that
it was being considered as a possible
terrorist incident and then it changed
it wasn't being considered as one and
now this news what what do you think
happened well I think it was an
abundance of caution this has been
described to me as a complex
investigation in terms of the evidence
that was there immediately to Han to
point to this man's motivation but
certainly last night yes
had told me that they did believe that
this was a terrorist incident I have to
say that in all of the statements they
didn't say that it wasn't they just said
that this stage they had not yet the
evidence obviously to treat it as a
terrorist incident but they were
receiving the help and cooperation of
counterterrorism police officers from
the southeast counterterrorism unit
based within Thames Valley Police and as
they have continued in the hours since
that attack to build a picture of this
individual and his possible motivation
they have now come to the conclusion
that it was indeed a terrorist incident